with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see API
management for surveillance of multi
cloud then stay tuned because here's
their rewind this talk is brought to you
by principal Bogle the p.m. for Apogee
and Kelsi Hightower at several demo
favorite it starts with Chris Paul
explaining some of the key advantages of
server lists the fact that it completely
abstracts away the underlying
infrastructure it enables you to be
agile because not worrying about that
infrastructure allows you to focus and
iterate on your product server list is
perfect for micro services which are
easier to maintain and the pair quickly
becoming the go-to solution for new
systems or monolith migrations and sir
girlis has evolved it started with
functions as a service and then
resonated so well that it expanded into
building full applications and now
serverless containers
oh and fun fact a service is basically
an API no stay with me here an API is a
contract around usage many service front
ends are actually api's you build
endpoints and then someone else will
access them api's are the simplest
mechanism for connected data experiences
between businesses within a business and
from a business to a user okay so if the
future is microservices and that's
basically a series of api's then we need
to meet our newest friend the API
management platform with any API it's
important to be able to simply
accomplish several operational tasks
control and manage access to the API
monitor usage quotas scale according to
demand analyze usage metrics and track
monetization so you see why API
management becomes a very critical
function as you start to roll out more
and more service applications and this
is where perl introduces Apogee edge the
analytic system and Apogee edge allows
you to measure every aspect of your API
traffic you can measure operational
details like response time and frequency
of different types of errors you can
find things that are interesting to your
business like where are people located
when they call your API S or which
applications are sending them
traffic okay so now in the talk Kelsey
takes the stage to show off what a
product like this can do he spends
nearly 20 minutes walking through a full
example for API management which
includes cloud run a simple go app curl
docker files cloud build Apache simple I
am auth and XML configs cloud functions
and api proxy and please don't ask me to
list all these again my point is that
demos like these end to end showcasing
the variety of frameworks and
applications you may be using together
is why we do cloud next so if you'd like
to see the full talk check out the link
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud youtube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]